what is the equation of the horizontal
line through the point negative four
comma six
so let's just visualize this once you
get the hang of it you might not have to
draw a graph
but for explanatory purposes it might be
useful so negative 4 comma 6. that's
going to be in the second quadrant
so if this is my
x-axis that is my
y-axis
let's see i'm going to go negative 4 in
the x-direction so 1 2
3 4
negative 4 and then 1 2 3 4
5 6 in the y direction so the point that
we care about is going to be right over
there negative 4
comma 6. and they're saying what is the
equation of the horizontal line
it is a horizontal line so it's just
going to go straight
left right like this
that is what the line would actually
look like so what is that equation
well for any x
y is going to be equal to 6.
this is the equation y is equal to 6. it
doesn't matter what x you input here
you're going to get y equals 6. it just
stays constant right over there so the
equation is y is equal to 6. let's do
another one of these
so here we are asked
what is the slope of the line
y is equal to negative four
so let's visualize it and then in the
future you might not have to draw it
like this
but let's just draw our axes again
x-axis
y-axis
and the slope of the line y equals
negative 4. so for whatever x you have
y is going to be negative 4. let's say
that's negative 4 right over there
and so
the line is y
the line is y equals negative 4. so i
can draw it like this
so what's the slope of that
well slope is change in y for given
change in x
and here no matter what i change my x y
doesn't change it stays at negative 4.
my change in y over change in x it
doesn't matter what my change in x is my
change in y is always going to be zero
it's constant so the slope here is going
to be equal to zero
y doesn't change no matter how much you
change x
let's do another one of these these are
this is fun
all right
so now they are asking us
what is the slope of the line x equals
negative 3
well let me graph that one
so
let's again draw my axes real fast x
axis
y axis x is equal to negative three so
negative one
negative two
negative three
and so this
line is going to look
let me
it's going to look like this no matter
what y
or
you could say no matter what y is x is
going to be equal to negative 3.
so
it would look like this x is equal to
negative 3.
so what's the slope here
well
it's undefined a vertical line has an
undefined slope remember you want to do
what's your change in y for change in x
change in y
for change in x
well you could think about what's the
slope as you approach this but once
again that could be some people would
say maybe it's infinite maybe it's
negative infinity but that's why it's
undefined a vertical line is going to
have an undefined slope
so go with undefined let's do one more
what is the equation of the vertical
line through negative 5 comma negative
2.
so let me do this one without even
drawing it and then i'll draw it right
after that so if we're talking about a
vertical if we're talking about a
vertical line that means that x doesn't
change x
doesn't
change if we were talking about a
horizontal line they would say y doesn't
change
so if x doesn't change that means that x
is just going to be equal to some
constant value
well if it contains the point negative 5
comma negative 2 so if it has the point
where x is equal to negative 5 and if x
never changes it's a vertical line well
that means this equation has to be x is
equal to negative 5.
and we can draw that out if it helps
so let me draw that out
so
oops let me make sure that's a straight
line
okay so we have x
and we have y
and so we have the point negative five
comma negative two so negative
one
two
three
four five
negative one two so we wanna go have a
vertical line that goes through that
point so a vertical line well that just
goes straight up and down so it's just
going to look like this
and so notice x never changes no matter
what y is x is equal to negative 5. this
has an undefined slope it is a vertical
line its equation is x is equal to
negative five